we're going this my name the rampant
welcome back to doom tress we are in a
[ __ ] hole right here know how a laser
gun
I didn't laser gun do you didn't burn
that [ __ ] are we really supposed to go
oh [ __ ] that's scary that thing just
kept shooting if you ever see a laser
gun don't stand in your way and be every
time that's tip the right there
I'm an idiot they really signed like the
half-life scumbags
the monsters in this game okay we need
to click things I'm clicking all right
active proceed without with caution okay
so I'm supposed to repair it I don't get
that let's throw some grenades up in
this [ __ ] oh we can go in here there we
go maybe I'm supposed to run
all right well let's go someone said
help me
don't shoot me later all right
No
all right
what the [ __ ] are you doing that died
what the hell am i doing now no bueno
nobody whoo
what are you doing in the darkness dude
calm down
I'm only getting help all right
looks like a [ __ ] penis stop scaring
me stop stop I don't like them what one
bit
Wow
what's so funny what are you trying it
ha ha die die die die Finn that laughing
no it's another one are you back look at
that beer belly shooting your pattern
oh it's punching time [ __ ]
oh you're slapping you're slapping out
whoa nice laughs pimpin of slapping holy
[ __ ] how about we stop [ __ ] dying
how about that all right
luckily I saved it it's just so dark
stop
I don't need armor shards that's not
what I need right now
take it [ __ ]
what that's just how I roll
hey you wanna present oh wait one second
then Bam Bam no fanny
not today fatty all right we really need
help really need help where is it
[ __ ] [ __ ]
shirt aliphatic Oh a mod Pam alright
we're good
PDA I knew you were there so dark come
on gas leak stop good extinguished good
good progress happy I'm happy
shallow look everybody here let's go in
here well you don't even have a hedgerow
make no sense at least I got shotgun
sound shells now
so where do I go now that I stopped the
gas leak oh the fire all right now I
remember I go back here
I think yep or maybe not
nope it's Sunday
son of a [ __ ] I think is it down here
maybe oh yes here it is all right all
right good
why does God know I'm on your side
real bad not color event he's working
the bell I know it well the cutscene
scares me now Oh what the hell
ah no he's calling Oh
bro why are you doing this alright if it
bleeds you can rape it oh come on Oh
wham bam bam there we go no prob do you
think this is all you got man you just
all you got - easy - [ __ ] easy breath
all right what let's go here shut up
whoa
Bow Wow all right keep going inside man
hole inside Matt huh I can't live
without a man
okay let's go up here cool we got stuff
yeah we got stuff let's go the other
home I don't trust you
[ __ ] off that's how you roll that's how
I get on delay dude do me a I don't get
lady whatever what do you want that's
all I got
whoa hey hey nice shot
mano-a-mano bitch-ass all right we're
good
it's gone pretty well so fine Bera whoa
battles actually helped me holy [ __ ]
what is parallel universe who's [ __ ]
me not throw a little present up for him
hey you want a present what
laughs [ __ ] a second three to have
stopped it
Samantha hey what's done what the hell
you don't like it I don't like you
either about it I know why I wouldn't be
honest about that ribbon no one likes
you ribbon even not even your mother I'm
sorry really
I'm not doing deciding these things so
that's actually going on today
Duke doggie stop why don't you leave me
alone I just want to get home to March
right that's not my home your home
whatever you could we could share it you
know hi goddamnit if I don't have one
now I got a clip flagging like a [ __ ]
oh no no Jeremy is back with demonic
seconds bye
hey Jenny you to sip it ourselves eating
grenades and [ __ ] whoa you see that
oh is that stop leave me alone I don't
want anything with you I didn't do any
mission authorized by P Harley I guess
we got to find it PDA and [ __ ] stay away
you're gay my guys doing science but I
got that guy I punch your ass [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] started a science and
[ __ ] better you you you you you you you
you stay down all right what are we
going we need to find a PDA way okay
bring it [ __ ]
well don't bring it then [ __ ] do I care
Oh stormy you started me drought I
thought it was all alone freakin spooky
lately yeah I get it
blowing a few circuits of his unstable
not calling careful of that gun straight
bullet into the glass shields to blow
the whole area all right
I'm gonna try and get this thing
stabilized I'll head to the science
office and I have this under control you
do what you have to do man oh yeah we
can go here now what da da
they always sneak up on you don't they
oh I can play that game I can play that
game
oh it's not so funny now is it [ __ ]
Oh No grenade eat it
eight more I'm generous that's just how
I am it's my personality I can't help
alright there we go
more oh you want more is this all you
got oh nice one barrels oh hell
first time ever down
no oh we've been here before God can we
go ahead yet what no we can't wasted an
ammo for nothing
stay down
[ __ ] spider I got only got Spidey I'm
really low and Emin right now oh thank
god
[ __ ] gotta get their ammo all right
here we go
I hate you I'm getting dodging yep I got
it right
oh [ __ ] well I'll actually have to end
this episode here but not confirm you
enjoyed it subscribe Humber today and
I'll see you next episode of whatever I
make
some Spanish dude says he's offended by
my bad Spanish